et plutôt bien parti dans cette élection
municipale les écologistes avec de bons
scores au premier tour vous voyez la
déclaration à présent d'hervé manchon
candidat europe ecologie les verts à
marseille on attend des élus aux mains
vertes et aux mains propres c'est à dire
d'une part répondre aux urgences
environnementales et climatiques mais
aussi répondre aux questions posées par
le manque de justice sociale et pas
seulement justice environnementale et
puis une plus grande transparence une
une démocratie plus directe
il y à une attente pour des
gouvernements qui pratiquerait une
politique autrement il ya eu des signaux
très forts de dérèglement climatique
d'urgence planétaire de 2 2 zones
terrestres que l'on prévoit comme étant
les futurs de futures zones inhabitables
avec des gens pourtant qui vivent encore
dessus il y a aussi une des choses
qu'ils interrogent notre mode de vie
par exemple quand donc la pandémie a été
annoncée à la veille du scrutin du
premier tour
beaucoup ont fui les villes elles sont
allées dans les dents des résidences
secondaires
ce n'est pas seulement une une chute une
peur du vieux ça interroge notre mode de
vie
on a des villes invivable on a un bien
vivre qui est une attente forte mais
auquel les métropoles et les vignes ne
répondent pas encore les espaces
urbanisés son sont encore sur un vieux
logiciel sur le logiciel du monde
d'après tout comme le monde économique
est encore sur le logiciel productivité
et ultralibéral voilà et nous nous
répondons à ces inquiétudes face à ces
logiciels
nous y répondrons nous sommes porteurs
de d'avenir